hello welcome to this video or
international master VCS oops who is
that Victoire shed night had never heard
of this guy Wow yeah this has recently
become popular sideline of the Queens
gambit accepted with no db5 surprisingly
a valid option from black and I have
very little experience with the
pollution and trying to put this Bishop
here so it's not in the way might be six
is a move that I'm not sure about if
what I'm doing against that Oh what is
he doing there Bishop t6
I'm trying to take my king side I am yes
yeah he is ok it looks weakening but at
least I get in 94 next and reorganized
by pieces and so
c5 of course I'm why not
see that Bishop can do something here
okay mystify to move I know that looks
it that doesn't look right we'll take
take a four maybe what am I doing here
this pin maybe that's a bit it's awkward
awkward pin threaten 8d take c5 I was
bishops doing a good job here that looks
good for white hmm not easy for him I
don't see a great move now for black he
takes you 5 s sir very annoying
should be sound something like that I
would still take on c5 yeah that's the
only kind of play along d takes you five
I think the ship f3 f3 the ship a ch-47
looks terrible taking is wrong that that
gets him out of the out of the pin 95 I
think this is good and I think it's good
and now let's see rook takes Bishop
takes Bishop takes is also not so
terrible this is this is this message
must be good that I can get in c 60 m
no okay I will kingi to get out of her
get out of this diagonal and then
convert
how can you even take their queen c3
some stuff like that be rather weird if
it is possible but ok what about rook b7
can i play it that looks on
and I can I actually should do that it's
more it just admitted this just much
more pressure
now if I've is that some stuff like that
that would be amazing I e5 Bishop c4
it's pretty good okay okay
don't see a clear way to win I mean it
looks good but how exactly am i winning
this game our queen doesn't have many
options cannot move the king I can
actually take on your six King g7 wasn't
helping one takes Queenie five green
tags i th Red Queen's take c7 with check
so just going back to see for I think it
would have been better time morning
let's bring this back here it's
defending this well here shoot should be
6 s coming okay no I can I can actually
play Bishop c4 no I cannot I can't do
this check check black resigns okay i
was a bit shaky from that winning
position around here i didn't play that
good at all I shouldn't have allowed all
those trades but it wasn't so clear how
to do that Jack yeah maybe that was a
bad idea and just just allow him to take
them 27 something like this where after
the capture will take with the pawn and
check the thought that keeping the rukon
would be more dangerous but it really
wasn't okay here oh I had a pair of a
stronger movie
this is winning Amy shy it's very cute I
know this quite nice but ok i'm happy
that i saw that move and Queenie aid was
stronger yeah he he he had a draw with
Queen to a one yeah yeah there are Jack
there's the draw and okay we both didn't
have much time giant he and I was
winning at the egg tough yeah I really
allowed a little bit too much there from
that great position okay thanks for
watching